I'm joined today by Barry Friedman who
teaches at new york university school of
law where he's the director of the
policing project he also is the author
of unwarranted policing without
permission which will be out in February
a berry is so great to talk to you give
us first just a general sense of the
book unwarranted and the issues that you
deal with their sure David great to be
here today so unwarranted is the review
of policing from everything from the
beat cop so issues so to stop and frisk
racial profiling all the way up to the
NSA bulk data collection a lot of
electronic surveillance drone stingrays
covers all of that with a basic theory
about how people ought to be engaged in
what the police are doing is there some
broader thesis that ties together all of
these maybe seemingly unrelated to some
people aspects of policing and law
enforcement is there what are the trends
that you're pointing to sure there's one
key thesis that I think will surprise
most people which is that we've lived in
an environment over the last several
years where we're pointing fingers at
the police and blaming them for lots of
things that they're doing but in my book
I point the singer somewhere differently
in part of the course but primarily a
top that the American people my idea is
that we wanted to be safe but we don't
want to know how it happens when we do
it indicates that we're just content
with how it happens but it's our
obligation as is true elsewhere
democracy to be involved in the front
end from the start and does this relate
to Rio we've talked in in the wake of
revelations from Edward Snowden for
example there have been a number of
interesting pieces written which point
out that depending on how recently
there's been a sort of notable prominent
terrorist attack or news event that
triggers feelings of lack of safety and
wanting safety that that seems to have a
huge influence on the public at large in
terms of the degree of surveillance or
level of militarization of law
enforcement may be that the average
person is willing to accept is there
something to that sure I mean you put
your finger on a broader program is a
problem is true all the time around
legislation
salience you know we tend to pay
attention to what just happened
immediately and it's really big and
really important the problem is that in
the rest of government even though we
focus on salient events we kind of keep
a steady stream going of sensibility by
being involved in regulation all the
time when it comes to policing the
people are largely excluded from what
policing agencies do until there's an
explosion like that and what we need to
find a way to do is to be involved you
know on an ongoing basis and setting
helping sets of strategies figuring out
what works figuring out one of the
methods by which we want to be believed
one of the topics in the book I guess
generally i'll call it policing in
secret can you give us some examples of
what might fall under that umbrella sure
you know I use one example to start that
chapter and as you know all the chapters
start with stories about leasing has
kind of gone off the rails too often
expect affecting very ordinary folks in
terrible ways and I start that chapter
talking about stingrays so stingrays are
a form of device that the police used to
track cell phones and they can be
incredibly valuable incredibly important
for finding somebody who's been
kidnapped or somebody's on the run but
they also can be used incredibly
intrusive Lee to track demonstrators or
protesters and the thing about stingrays
is we the people had no knowledge that
they were being used the federal Justice
Department had worked with the
manufacturer to provide them to local
police helped fund them under agreements
that in tempted to say that their very
existence be kept secret even from
judges in cases when when when it gets
the police applied for a warrant or
something and so it started to leak out
and what happens when we keep things
secret is that when they leak out people
get annoyed they get angry and often
they get angry enough that we stop using
that kind of surveillance all together
so the thesis of the book is we need a
middle ground we need to be informed we
need to make sensible solutions on the
front end about how surveillance is
going to take place so they're all safe
but in a way in which we're comfortable
yeah as far as the Stingray I'm sure
you've read some of the the descriptions
of cases in which in order to shield the
existence and use of stingray technology
law enforcement official
were sort of simultaneously building a
sort of side by side or a concurrent of
case essentially so that by the time
they got to trial or at the time at
which they had to talk to a judge about
a warrant they had a sort of shadow
chain of evidence that hid the existence
of stingray technology do I have that
more or less right yeah it's incredible
they call it parallel construction yeah
so it's exactly what you just described
and the idea is we don't want anybody to
know we're doing this so once we learn
some information then we can construct
an alternate story about how we got
there you know it's always easier to
solve a maze by going in from the
solutions to the middle and so that's
pretty much what they do and what's
incredible and you have to understand
how bipartisan the concern about these
issues ought to be when it started to
leak out what really motivated change
was a joint letter from at the time that
sort of two heads of the Senate
Judiciary Committee one from the
Democratic side Patrick Leahy and the
other chuck Grassley basically writing
the FBI on tank what's going on and when
they got initial answers their responses
you know that's not enough we want to
know what's going on and that's that's
the right response we the people ought
to know upfront what's going on we ought
to weigh in we're not crazy we're very
sensible and then we ought to make
decisions about what's the right way to
be pleased and in terms of making those
decisions and as you talked about
finding a middle ground and being
upfront about the methods that are being
used I've interviewed many people who
are on different places I guess on the
ideological spectrum with regard to
policing and privacy and surveillance
etc what's your opinion as to whether
the demonstrable effectiveness of a
technique or piece of technology at
preventing crime should be considered
when evaluating whether it should be
allowed well let's use the most obvious
thing in the world to me what you just
said which is should we know how
effective something is before we permit
it or use it it's not just a question of
intrusion by the way we spend billions
of dollars on public safety and the one
thing we all want to be is safe so I'll
tell you something interesting I
I've started a not-for-profit to work on
these issues called the policing project
and one of our focuses on cost-benefit
analysis of policing so everywhere else
the government where there's a lot of
money being spent we try to answer the
simple question are we doing more good
than harm are we doing it a
cost-effective way are we being
effective in a way that does the least
damage if those are the most obvious
questions around policing and yet we
don't ask them there's almost no cost
benefit analysis Don look around
policing that we can learn a tremendous
amount now their reasons for this but
but as a bottom line conclusion the
answers gotta beat it does need to
change in the third part of the upcoming
book unwarranted you get into 21st
century policing and I think that this
relates to the cost-benefit analysis
significantly insofar as as technology
continues to improve and become more
ubiquitous new technologies the cost for
using those technologies continues to go
down do you think that that will play a
role in the types of surveillance
technology cloud storage government
databases etc that will be employed by
law enforcement in the coming years
today there's a great question and you
put it in an interesting way you are
absolutely right that the cost of
surveillance techniques will go down and
for that reason I think what we'll see
in the future is for example much more
in the way of surveillance and less
perhaps in the way of use of force which
occupies the minds of a lot of people
today because we'll just keep an eye on
folks that's good right right I'm sorry
that sounds good maybe at the surface
well you know there's huge promise in
these technologies which is to the
extent that they can help us focus on
and target bad guys we should all be in
favor of that but the one thing I did
want to say though is that when you talk
about the cost of surveillance you know
it's not just the cost of the gadget
that's what we forget around bleaching
the coffee it's the cost of the gadget
but then also any good cost-benefit
analysis without you know what about the
cost of privacy what about the cost of
security both security from crime but
also security for the government so
that's the kind of thing we have to get
better and analyzing as we move forward
into this brave new world but I would
agree with you that there's a terrific
opportunity here
how do you weigh or evaluate the value
of some of those intangibles especially
when the value of privacy may be
different to different people how can
you even start to dig into that issue so
again a great question and it's not easy
I think it's a primary reason we don't
do cost-benefit analysis now around
three thing is that we you know how to
tackle those hard questions but what I
will point out is that everything you
just you know suggestion with regard to
policing would have been equally true in
the environmental area 10 15 20 years
ago really hard questions about how to
weigh the use of progress and certain
substances or chemicals and society
against the risks of harm's sometimes
risks of harm that we don't know much
about that affect people in very
different ways but there's really smart
people out there in the world who work
on exactly these kinds of questions in
fact we're gathering a bunch of them
here at NYU Law School in February's to
start talking about it and the trick is
to start to try to you know tease them
apart and reach answers so that we're
spending our public safety dollars
lively last thing I'd like to touch on
is the Constitution when we talk about
21st century policing to use the term
from your book and Technology do the
constitutional issues get more complex
what is a search without a warrant when
you're using technology what is even a
search what constitutes a general search
versus a specific one it is this going
to get even muddier sure so the book as
you know is divided into three parts the
first about democratic policing the
second about constitutional policing in
the third about 21st century policing
and what I try to do in that last part
is show how if you get fixed in the
correct way on what the constitutional
issues are something that we often don't
do in the courts do a terrible job of if
you if you slow down and think about
what the constitutional rules are
generally then it gets easier to apply
them to the technologies that they come
but we really need to do that and courts
have made an absolute mess of this and
with the you know wave of technology
that's coming we've got to get our head
screwed on right about it I'll remind
you we've been talking about the book
unwarranted policing without permission
it's going to be out in
februari and we've been speaking with
the book's author Barry Friedman who
teaches at NYU School of Law thank you
so much for talking to us about this
been great agree with you David take
care